il faut reporter le débat sur les 110
kilomètres/heure alors croyez-moi je
formule le set
je formule cette proposition en
spécialistes parce que j'ai présenté
beaucoup de grands plans très ambitieux
avec beaucoup de choses formidables qui
ont parfois été résumée à une mesure où
une petite phrase et ce serait
profondément injuste que tout votre
travail se résumer à cette proposition
je vous le dis très sincèrement j'en
comprends l'objectif mais vous avez
beaucoup débattu et vous l'avez redit
dans vos propos pour que ça marche il ne
faut pas stigmatiser les gens il ne faut
pas les diviser il faut réussir à les
embarquer tous ensemble si on fait ça je
vous l'écris nos concitoyens qui sont
dans des territoires les plus enclavées
qui parfois mettre tous les jours 45
minutes une heure en utilisant les
grands axes pour aller travailler qui
ont besoin pour retrouver leurs familles
de les utiliser dans la vie s'organise
par ces transports ils vont dire ok leur
projet est un projet il n'y a pas de
place pour moi c'est un projet de durban
je n'existe pas c'est pas la réponse que
vous voulez apporter c'est pas vrai
c'est pas la caricature jeu
moi j'ai lu vos propositions je vous ai
écouté je viens de vous entendre et donc
je pense que il faut faire mature et se
débat dans la société
celui de la vitesse et autres il faut
aussi que les gens là chaque fois
plusieurs options mais ne donnons jamais
le sentiment à certains de nos
concitoyens qu'on les comptes
culpabiliser ou qu'on les met à l'écart
et donc je propose de repousser ce débat
je ne voudrais pas que vous connaissiez
le même sort comme comme moi c'est à
dire avoir des mois de travail qui
s'abîme dans une polémique
le secteur privé a aussi un rôle à jouer
et c'est notamment pour cela je le dis
clairement que je suis en désaccord
j'avais dit que j'avais quelques joker
avec la taxe de 4 % sur les dividendes
que vous proposez
je ne dis pas qu'il ne faut pas
réorienter une partie des
investissements vers des vers des
investissements plus vert mais m sur
tous les investissements
une taxe c'est réduire notre chance
d'attirer les investissements
supplémentaires
je crois à la croissance de notre
économie je crois un modèle qui innovent
nos entreprises ont besoin d'innover
elles ont donc besoin d'attirer des
capitaux français et étrangers sur notre
sol pour innover et changer de modèle
nous sommes déjà un pays qui est très
fiscalisés je pense qu accroître la
fiscalité la fiscalité pour répondre à
ce défi n'est pas la bonne manière
par contre continuer à réfléchir sur une
fiscalité plus incitative vers ce qui
est plus vert et qui doit donc être plus
rentable qui fit près je suis garant de
nos institutions et mon rôle c'est de
veiller à tout ce qui pourrait mettre en
cause l' équilibre des pouvoirs et les
valeurs qui fondent la république
or tel que proposé la rédaction pour le
pré en bulles menacent de placer la
protection de l'environnement au dessus
des libertés publiques au dessus même de
nos règles démocratiques et c'est
pourquoi je ne souhaite pas reprendre
cette proposition parce que je considère
qu'elle serait contraire à notre texte
constitutionnel à l'esprit nos valeurs
et d'ailleurs je crois pouvoir dire que
j'ai compris ce que vous proposiez me
semble-t-il vous proposer un projet
humaniste et tout ce que nous sommes en
train de faire pour l'environnement
toutes ces transformations
c'est non pas parce que nous mettons la
nature au dessus de nous mais parce que
nous considérons que défendre les droits
de la nature est un de nos devoirs en
tant qu homme au sens générique du terme
c'est pourquoi il est essentiel de le
mettre au bon niveau mais de ne pas
mettre un droit de la nature au dessus
des droits humains parce que je crois
que ce n'est pas cohérent avec le projet
la philosophie des lumières qui porte
notre république